[Music]
in Karma's a [ __ ] news live by hey
[ __ ] number one podcast and that is now
facing trial after tossing a fridge off
a cliff and mocking the idea of
recycling tossing a fridge off a cliff
yes yeah like and pretty much thrown
away like giant littering Oh exactly
giant littering so this happened in
Spain and I will show you the video yeah
get rid of this [ __ ] they drove all the
way to his cliff mm-hmm I've been there
man
was it to make a point no he's trying to
get out of this [ __ ] no no he's not
trying to be fun really just trying to
get rid of this [ __ ] oh yeah you ever
had a broken fridge like aw man I got a
[ __ ] tickets to the dump or some [ __ ]
[ __ ] that and then you take it to like a
hillside and you just kick it off the
side have I ever done that no but I have
seen appliances all around our nature
and I'm just like how does this happen
nature oh you never drive around you're
like why is there a washer here in the
middle of the mountain dude because
because it [ __ ] like me white trash
people like me so so when I was a kid we
had a freezer that broke and my dad we
we took it to this place because we
looked it up it's down the street you
can take your appliances there and drop
it off but when we got there we realized
the whole part the whole parking lot was
empty
so my dad's like oh cool so we don't
have to like take it out put it on dolly
and like walk it up or anything all my
exhaust it's like he opens the door and
we're still driving he's like just
[ __ ] like ticket just kick it out
it fell out while we're going like 6
miles an hour and the fridge like broken
down statute of limitations has
definitely passed
I am completely legally fine thank you
some employee that was working there
watch they're like you are the
[ __ ] that did this [ __ ] well
suppose we you could take it there and
they will try to repurpose it to Oh
broke now they can't even sell it maybe
they could sell it maybe they could sell
the handle for parts I feel like this
men wanted to see how I would look like
falling down the cliff
right that is a that is a good
scientific approach like it's a thing
that people would like to do just to
throw something down and just see it
fall I don't think people girl I think
it's just guys I think yes that's true
aside I don't know any girl that's a kid
you are going through zip you don't know
let's do it
do you guys have this feeling so what
I'm like hi somewhere right if I throw
something like an egg or something off
and or like something into the water
when it's floating through the air my
balls are shrinking cuz you think you're
an identifying with the and I feel this
feeling of like like this until it hits
the water or the ground do we have a
feeling with early but if you throw
something over over the pier or
something you're just like my budget
does nothing what if you do pitch what
have you do a peach or something that
resembled I would get scared that I'm
like [ __ ] I hope it doesn't hit
something down there that's a living at
that time yeah so I wouldn't throw the
peach over I probably just toss it on
the sides I'm like awesome think I need
this yeah I do that my balls shrink
because I am coming when you're shooting
to come over the cliff yes I see I see
you ever come off a cliff
never he's afraid of heights I mean if
it wasn't I do like throwing things from
high places though it's pretty fun it's
like back in the day as like water
balloons you just you've done that yeah
just a scene where just I don't know
just to see it explode you don't pumpkin
before oh I feel like I have that's fun
I think I'm okay with biodegradable
Leary yeah this is gonna fall apart
yeah some birds gonna eat it yeah we're
dog [ __ ] by the gradable mm-hmm their
own dog [ __ ] he's got to get out of the
bag
cuz the bag yeah the back traps it
little-known fact or you get
biodegradable back and you're good oh
yeah yeah wait so can we see this video
I was trying to show you so this is a
video of him throwing it over and also
after this this first video when the
police posted on Twitter trying to find
this man they found the man and they
made his ass go down there and pick it
no that's what the second part of this
video shows saying recycling littering
[ __ ] it's so funny though damn that's
crazy
why to Spain look like la forest and
[ __ ] yeah you [ __ ] oh man why is that
blurry I don't know close off or
something no wait is that the cops
recording them now picking it up yeah
that's [ __ ] funny you gotta do all
this work now I don't know how they
blurt it yeah yeah why'd let me see them
before throw it down unblurred mm-hmm
what a [ __ ] bunch of [ __ ] bases yep
so I love this this is a good lesson
Randy freakin schmutz I kind of
something more just like some guys would
do be it roll absolutely I enjoyed the
roll like I don't I disagree with the
littering me too there's something
really awesome about seeing like a stove
or oven or even a television just fly
down a mountain that's so boring
really yes what's so fun about it I
don't know like that's like when guys
like to hit the top of like doors I do
that yeah I feel like it's a guy I would
if I could I don't I don't know if it's
a gender thing guys I'm sorry but I like
find joy in this too like whenever we go
to I don't know like for example we went
to ison there were these like chunks of
ice and I just had to break them apart
with my foot and pick up the chunk and
just store it in the water in the river
and I'm like it was so much fun yeah
yeah maybe it's not a judgment do you
ever walk around you see mushrooms you
you just gotta kick home
no I gotta kick home I have to kick them
too I have to kick him hard I [ __ ] mom
like which kind of ones that are
why them stock or the skinny whichever
ones the ones that like just grow after
it rains and [ __ ] doing that - yeah
there's some real big boys next to me
right now on me and he's a little
walking back that weight well Nikki's
always there and she's always like don't
get a doctor don't do what if they're
poisonous you have to kick up right
where somebody eats it but because I
[ __ ] is eating something off the
sidewalk using gravy dogs or but because
I haven't gotten to kick them they got
so big and now they're looking so juicy
I want to keep all man yeah we got to
kick it before dies I know yeah there's
nothing like kicking a juicy mushroom
where's the driveway I'm gonna kick him
tonight interest or is it serious issue
sets a reminder there's already been
picked don't say that don't say that I
hope not well anyway so this guy here he
was fined forty five thousand euros
which is about seventy four thousand two
hundred seventy seven dollars that's
ridiculous that's the [ __ ] law I left
insanity bro that's what they should do
to litterers over here yes my litter
well there are there are fines for
littering is only $1000 a lot of money
it's not enough to make people go I
regret this for the rest of my life
dude 75 grand for this that's pretty bad
littering you picked it up though cuz
they made him off or something no that
was part of the order - oh yes event hey
there saying that so there was this
court they're saying that they're
deciding whether or not the man would
face further fines for environmental
crime and also there was this
investigation and police said that the
waste management company that employed
this man who will also face sanctions
because it - had failed to properly
dispose of old refrigerator oh so they
weren't even his own appliances he just
worked for a company and that's it okay
so why don't we charge the US military
for every drone strike they blow up some
cliffside or some [ __ ] Hill you
should just buy refrigerator inside yeah
the environmental impact of a fridge
chilling somewhere like just limit
imagine it deteriorated and like
overtime and like it affected like a
poison you know $75,000 one of the
damage bro he doesn't do it again cuz he
obviously did it multiple times the
earth always inherits these things bro
it breaks them down over time from
slowly that's right it's only gonna take
two billion years but it's gonna go back
death monster yeah but what if the
family of beavers used the fridge for
the new home they took it over [ __ ] yeah
you guys are fort guy getting charged
$75 you [ __ ] up I am a little bit and
you got a pig 75 K well that's in Spain
too so that's why there people are more
in order than the freakin Americans do
we know that yeah no we don't I just
want to go I just don't want to be wrong
I think a better punishment maybe where
they have to get trampled by those Bulls
that run through the alley what the what
did the Bulls do no they're having the
good times trampling on the humans the
Bulls the humans are in the way and then
the Bulls get hurt because a human-sized
running out the Bulls the Bulls having
life I've never seen the Bulls get hurt
by trampling over the humans they trip
and then they end up like smacking their
face on the wall I've never seen that
never seen a bad trip I've never seen
bull running bloopers so no I'm not
maybe I got to look for the bloopers the
blonde the wrong video bloopers are when
the bull messes I like it because
there's guys running away and then
there's just all these bulls like
throwing them up in the air I love that
yeah but not for fridge that fridge
dumping well he was saying you should go
there I think so what's the appropriate
fine for you then buy 10 G's I think
like cleaning up [ __ ] cleaning up a
bunch of [ __ ] outside road or something
like that all community service yeah
[ __ ] you're picking up more more planes
picking up more appliances exactly and
they have to be pantsless I'm for that
okay I like doing mosquito season yep
what attracts mosquitoes put down on
them Joe pictures probably mid dress him
up in yellow peanut in yellow so bees
listing him oh maybe he has to go on
mosquito killing duty for a year
he's out here in the fogger for doing
this [ __ ] yeah yeah that's making beats
and yes it'd be naked I'm for that
oh yeah so they could come and bite them
everywhere I like that
well I imagine that was like a community
service thing to just kill mosquitoes
great tennis racket thing yeah the
tennis racket like that's better than
like just paying 75,000 to where does it
go to yeah also the environmental
efforts or the private prison industry
[ __ ] having them do free labor
basically I've got them I like Saturdays
for us yeah I like that idea kill those
[ __ ] skiers
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]